hbo's game of thrones came to an end in
the spring of 2019 even its biggest fans
have to admit that many story arcs
simply don't add up these are some of
the most puzzling questions game of
thrones left in its wake spoilers for
the entire series to follow
as game of thrones begins king robert
baratheon is on the throne of westeros
right away viewers learn about his
famous conquest of the seven kingdoms
with ned stark by his side after
overthrowing the raving king aerys
targaryen roberts became fiercely
protective of his throne seeking to kill
any young targaryen threats
i'll kill every targaryen i get my hands
on
in the aftermath of robert's death his
illegitimate successor joffrey baratheon
takes that mission several steps forward
ordering the systematic killing of
robert's many bastard children to ensure
his own status as king unfortunately for
joffrey he misses one important bastard
gendry a gifted young blacksmith gendry
goes on to survive the entire series but
his baratheon blood never proves to be
climactic just before the end of the
show daenerys targaryen legitimizes him
making him lord gendry despite the fact
that doing so could challenge her own
claim to the iron throne
one of the most famously infuriating
moments in thrones's final season is
daenerys's lightning-fast decision to
slaughter thousands of innocents in
king's landing as daenerys and her team
prepare to attack king's landing and
queen cersei lannister cersei's brother
and daenerys's right-hand man tyrion
tells the targaryen error that when she
hears the bell's ring in westeros's
capital city she must back off as he
explains the bells mean surrender
if the city surrenders they will ring
the bells and raise the gates please if
you hear them ringing the bells call off
the attack this would be all well and
good except that during another crucial
battle set at king's landing varys tells
tyrion that the bells ring for horror
typically related to war
daenerys begins the show as the khaleesi
of a wild dothraki horde after losing
and gaining control of these proud horse
lords many times over she eventually
makes her way to westeros with a massive
dothraki army at her back after losing
one of her dragons to the night king
daenerys finds herself at a disadvantage
as the white walkers head towards
westeros as the battle begins seemingly
most if not all of her dothraki warriors
charge and are immediately snuffed out
by the army of the dead however just a
few episodes later after daenerys
overtakes king's landing the camera pans
across what looks like thousands of
dothraki warriors enthralled by her
speech about conquering the world david
benioff himself said that the battle of
winterfell was quote essentially the end
of the dothraki so how does daenerys
have so many horse lords left after that
frigid battle
in the series finale tyrion is given
free reign to choose the next monarch he
decides that bran stark who was quote
the best story should be crowned bran
the broken and rule the seven kingdoms
whether or not bran actually does have
the best story this choice makes little
sense bran has become the inhuman and
omniscient three-eyed raven as he has
made clear he cares about little
including the throne after game of
thrones spent years signaling that a
great leader would be honorable as well
as cunning why does his sister sansa who
is both get a junior queenship while her
brother gets the real prize
game of thrones biggest mystery always
concerned the white walkers an undead
race of beings who live in the far north
beyond the wall the white walkers and
their leader the night king pose an
enormous threat to all of westeros as
the army of the dead will eventually
make its way to the seven kingdoms in
wage war throughout the series viewers
get small pieces of information about
the walkers including that they are
given babies as offerings from humans
who live north of the wall who they turn
into tiny walkers however in the season
8 episode the long night when the
walkers finally make their way to
winterfell arya stark dispatches the
night king without too much trouble and
the mysteries surrounding the white
walkers die with him and his entire army
in the seventh season several of
daenerys allies go on an ill-advised
mission north of the wall to try and
prove to cersei that the white walkers
are real southerners like cersei
consider them to be a myth thus tyrion
proposes capturing a white and bringing
it to show cersei however this plan is
foolish right from the start whites
rarely travel alone so trying to capture
a single white and return it in one
piece is essentially a suicide mission
also cersei is certainly shocked by the
white when she sees it but she wages war
against them anyway and all that
daenerys's suicide squad has to show for
their trouble is a stray white and a fel
dragon
after daenerys swoops in to rescue the
gang she suffers a major loss when the
night king shoots one of her dragons
viserion out of the sky the image of
assyrian's eye reopening with its new
blue hue is definitely one of thrones
coolest visuals but the mechanics of how
the night king and his army retrieve the
dragon from underneath the ice raises
some questions earlier in that same
episode the white capturers keep walkers
at bay by isolating themselves on a rock
surrounded by water as whites can't swim
if that's so how did they retrieve
viserion beyond that the army of the
dead uses enormous chains to drag
viserion to the surface where did they
get those and how did they attach them
to the dragon underwater
on game of thrones one of the most
difficult obstacles is travel for that
reason early seasons of game of thrones
are more or less devoted to long
journeys making it clear that people
like daenerys who is trying to get to
westeros have a long way to go however
as the show continued writers focused
less on westeros's sprawling landscape
to the point where the rules of time and
space seem to stop mattering entirely
journeys that would have once taken a
season and a half eventually only take a
couple of minutes gentry can run from a
mountaintop north of the wall to send a
raven to daenerys who arrives on a
dragon shortly thereafter suspension of
disbelief is fine for a show that
involves dragons and magic but game of
thrones space-time continuum develops
not just a tear but some pretty enormous
holes
melisandre is a cryptic priestess of
roller the lord of light initially
melisandre who serves stannis baratheon
until his death is the only red priest
viewers meet but others eventually
appear beyond their fire related powers
they deliver prophecies especially
melisandre who makes sweeping
proclamations about chosen ones and
rightful kings stannis baratheon
warrior of light your sword awaits you
these prophecies are all exciting in the
beginning but by the time game of
thrones draws to a close none of them
have been fulfilled when all is said and
done melisandre's predictions have
little to no bearing on anything in the
show's outcome and are never explained
at all
brawn is a fan favorite as the beloved
wisecracking mercenary who spends time
with both jaime and tyrion lannister
throughout the series but a bizarre
plotline takes place during the eighth
season in which braun agrees to kill
jaime and tyrion simply because cersei
offered him money he threatens the
brothers with the crossbow then isn't
seen again until the finale by then
tyrion has made him lord of highgarden
which he promised braun in exchange for
his and jaime's lives as well as master
of coin to king bran earlier in the
series brawn says he's never borrowed
money and doesn't know how it works so
making a man who can't figure out the
concept of alone the master of coin
seems unwise
game of thrones is home to plenty of
moments that require viewers to put
aside some of their logic and reason
especially when it comes to injuries
after characters like cal drogo die of
afflictions like blood poisoning you'd
think that a serious injury might take a
character down once in a while both
jaime and arya endure brutal stab wounds
to the stomach during fights arya loses
the tussle with the waif in season 6
while jaime struggles against euron
greyjoy in the final season and yet
neither person seems much troubled by
these grievous injuries jaime makes it
into the red keep to find cersei while
arya somehow leaps into a canal swims
across braavos and is eventually cured
by a cup of soup and a good night's
sleep armor can be effective against
knives but apparently being a series
regular can save you from multiple
stomach wounds as well
beyond her unhelpful prophecies
melisandre does a fair amount of magic
on game of thrones much of which
concerns blood sacrifices to help
stannis game the throne she sacrifices
his followers and countrymen to the
flame she steals king's blood from
gendry for a ritual that will destroy
any usurpers to the iron throne she even
convinces stannis to burn his own
daughter shireen alive to win the war of
the five kings shireen dies screaming
her mother hangs herself and stannis
loses anyway with all that in mind many
viewers were terrified of who or what
melisandre would sacrifice after she
revived a murdered jon snow this time
however melisandre doesn't have to
sacrifice anyone she just brings jon
back from the dead if she's capable of
resurrection with nothing but her own
power why did she have to kill all those
other people
after daenerys husband drogo sustains an
infected wound the dragon queen can't
keep her husband from a grisly death
bereaved but newly self-confident
daenerys sets her sight on westeros
putting her romantic life on the back
burner though daenerys takes a few
lovers she never truly falls in love
again until jon snow arrives and the two
fall head over heels for each other
putting their lackluster chemistry aside
as well as the fact that they're
actually on to nephew daenerys risking
her quest for the iron throne over a
lover is wildly inconsistent with her
character it doesn't make sense until
you consider that as a plot device it
forces jon to face some internal
conflict about killing the woman who's
not just his queen but his lover
samwell tarly might be one of game of
thrones most lovable characters but he's
definitely not the toughest fighter
while out in the far north with a few
other men from the night's watch sam and
his black clad brothers hear a horn
sound three times indicating that white
walkers have been spotted while sam's
compatriots make a run for it he can't
catch up and so he hides behind a rock
this leads to a thrilling scene in which
sam watches an entire army of walkers
make their way towards the wall but it
also raises questions not only would he
not be able to get ahead of the army but
a walker atop an undead horse makes
prolonged eye contact with him the white
walkers will kill anything in their path
besides the fact that he's a main
character why is sam any different
when audiences first meet jon snow and
ned stark they're told that jon is ned's
shameful bastard the product of an
affair with a tavern wench but ned
prices his honor above all else making
the situation seem a little shady
ultimately the truth is revealed jon
isn't a bastard at all but is the
legitimate product of ned's sister
lyanna stark and daenerys brother prince
rhaegar targaryen who married in secret
as lyanna laid dying with robert
baratheon's forces approaching she
begged her brother to keep jon's real
identity a secret to save him from
robert's sword this is true enough but
the lengths to which ned goes to keep
this secret are extreme for years ned's
loving wife caitlyn resents jon as
shameful proof of her husband's
infidelity couldn't ned have told his
wife the real story
jon snow has one of the toughest
journeys on game of thrones yet somehow
he ends up with a reasonably happy
ending after helping daenerys conquer
king's landing he realizes that his
queen and lover has turned evil in her
quest for power in the aftermath of her
massacre of king's landing civilians he
stabs her for the good of the realm
though daenerys loyal soldiers are
furious a deal is reached and jon is
banished back to the night's watch
landing him right back where he began
jon is always happiest when he's north
of the wall so at face value this seems
like a perfect ending however there's a
catch the night's watch no longer has
any reason to exist the night's watchmen
protected the wall in the realm from
white walkers but without them there's
nothing for the night's watch to do it's
a neat ending to send jon back to his
brothers in black but it also makes
absolutely no sense
pretty much everything that euron
greyjoy does in the final two seasons of
game of thrones makes no sense as
thrones's final conflict draws near
euron's niece and nephew yara and theon
steal his best ships euron manages to
build 1 000 ships in pretty quick order
and from there he gains perfect aim
overnight taking down one of daenerys
typically impervious dragons with a
perfect shot from a moving ship no less
he's at multiple major disadvantages yet
none of them seem to actually matter in
a show that prides itself on taking
fantasy tropes seriously euron greyjoy
stands out like a lucky sore thumb
out of all the characters on game of
thrones tywin lannister is probably the
smartest man in all of westeros tywin is
a political master who stops at nothing
in his quest to elevate the lannisters
this makes one of his personal
relationships extraordinarily confusing
during the show's second season while
arya is on the run from king's landing
in the wake of her father's execution
she ends up being tywin's cupbearer at
harrenhal the two strike up a solid
rapport especially when tywin realizes
that she's well educated however that
fact alone should have revealed arya's
identity taiwan knows that one of the
two star girls has escaped and arya's
knowledge betrays her highborn status
almost immediately tywin may be the
cleverest man in westeros but apparently
even his considerable brain has its
limits
it takes daenerys until the start of
thrones's seventh season to arrive in
westeros she makes a triumphant return
to dragonstone her ancestral home in a
near silent scene that closes the
seventh season's premiere daenerys
strides across the shore she barely
remembers at last she's finally ready to
take on her westerosi foes however
there's one thing about this scene that
doesn't add up after stannis deaths why
doesn't anyone acquainted with the
lannister forces even bother trying to
take dragonstone as a coastal stronghold
it would have been wise for daenerys
enemies to send even just a few soldiers
to protect the place where she was born
especially because they likely knew she
would return
cersei might be a vicious power player
throughout thrones but she does truly
love her children watching her lose her
two younger children in incredibly
tragic ways almost makes you pity the
villainous
she was good
from her first breath she was so sweet
i don't know where she came from
however we know long before her last
child dies that losing children was her
destiny in the fifth season's premiere a
young cersei meets a witch who tells her
that she will have three children and
that their crowns and shrouds will both
be golden yet in the show's second
episode cersei tells caitlyn stark that
she once had a brown-haired baby
presumably the baby she had with robert
baratheon that would mean she had four
children making this otherwise correct
prophecy suddenly null and void in the
series's final episode bran is chosen as
the next king of the seven kingdoms but
before anyone can celebrate sansa asks
that the north which has always belonged
to the starks maintain its independence
bran agrees and sansa's crowned queen in
the north it's pretty strange that
neither yara greyjoy who has been
angling for the iron island's
independence nor the unnamed prince of
dorne a region with a long history of
independence from the other kingdoms
asks for the same thing sansa gets what
she wants so why don't they ask too
instead of accepting the fact that their
precious kingdoms remain under bran's
rule
during thrones's fifth and sixth seasons
arya undergoes a massive transformation
when she trains at the house of the
undying in braavos it is here where she
learns to be a faceless assassin and the
mysterious girl known as the waif plays
a huge role in it as the apparent
right-hand woman to jack and hagar the
waif despises arya beating her without
mercy after arya loses her sight and
eventually trying to assassinate her
aside from setting up conflict for arya
however there's not really much reason
for the wave to exist and her presence
and animosity towards arya go completely
unexplained once arya leaves braavos we
never see either jaqen or the waif again
and it's even more unclear as to why the
waif ever existed
after learning to assume other people's
faces and kill her enemies in braavos
arya proves herself to be a formidable
assassin taking down her enemies as soon
as she arrives in westeros for years
however one enemy looms above all the
rest cersei lannister it seems like a
foregone conclusion for much of the
series that arya will be the one to kill
cersei however arya does not kill cersei
instead the hound warns her that killing
cersei will end up killing her as well
as the red keep is on the verge of
collapse somehow that one sentence works
and arya turns back and cersei's death
fails to bring arya's story to a close
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]